a bombshell report to share with you a
famous lawyer was soliciting money to
pay women making sexual misconduct
allegations against candidate Donald
Trump during the 2016 campaign getting
paid to accuse the candidate you don't
think that's an incentive to fabricate
stories we're gonna discuss it all with
Alan Dershowitz I'll also talk to White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders
about the constant barrage of media
attacks some against her personally and
the president but first the Democrats me
to suicide mission that's the focus of
tonight's angle okay do you remember
what I told you just a few nights ago
female politicians and activists should
also be really careful where they take
this because someday maybe men might
decide to turn the tables on them and
start launching their own maybe it's
called hashtag men to movement with wild
decades-old complaints against women in
positions of power you don't think it
could happen
just watch well that didn't take long
did it the first casualty is Andrea
Ramsay a Democrat running for Congress
in Kansas she's dropping out of the race
after the Kansas City Star asked her
about accusations in a 12 year old
lawsuit the suit claimed Ramsey sexually
harassed and retaliated against a male
subordinate who had rejected her
advances according to multiple sources
the man who filed the case reached a
settlement with the company and court
documents show that the case was
dismissed after mediation back in 2006
look people settle suits all the time
they settle them for things that aren't
true as well because they're just a
nuisance and they'd rather not bother
them but drop out of the race more than
a decade later for this I think that's
ridiculous but this is the climate that
Democrats have created it is a trap that
they themselves are now falling into and
believe me I probably agree with that
candidate on nothing she's a favorite of
Emily's list
I'm sure she and I wouldn't agree on
most issues but I think that situation
is appalling Nancy Pelosi
and the rest of the new liberal morality
brigade on Capitol Hill are so feeding
on their own members they've opened up
an ethics probe into a Nevada Democratic
congressman Ruben queuing over
allegations of sexual harassment
now Pelosi and others have asked you and
to step down but he's refusing he vows
to clear his name again another Democrat
and the witch hunt continues and he
questions Pelosi's newfound me to
immorality know why does he do that huyn
says that Pelosi and the Democratic
Party knew about the allegations against
him a year ago he said they looked into
them they didn't find anything and they
continued investing millions in my
campaign he told that to ABC News they
went out there and they campaign for me
well we invited him on the show tonight
but sadly he declined my friends this me
to madness is spinning dangerously out
of control and I think the people get it
here are some of my listeners today on
the radio I definitely think that this
has gone to the extreme and they have to
do something to stop this I'm very
sensitive to any type of a sexual
assault but I feel that this hashtag
this hashtag that has become almost a
fad from personal experience people have
been really abused sexually abused are
so upset about this moment many to
movement simply because they're making a
joke out of the real people who've
really been abused by the way the phone
lines today were jammed with female
callers now speaking of jokes now
Democrats are calling for the president
to resign over misconduct allegations
you know the ones you heard before the
2016 election but as the Washington Post
pointed out this morning the Democrats
may be over playing their hand ahead of
2018 and 2020 this is the way I look at
it the left in their blind rage against
Trump are unable to see the obvious
they're near constant demonization of
Trump it's starting to wear a little
thin and I think it could end up
backfiring big time
think about it after tax reform has
passed the economy continues to grow and
more Americans are able to keep more of
their own money how much residents will
old accusations partisan leaks and
identity politics really end up having
will voters other than like the really
hardcore activists in the donor class
really have the appetite for the growing
calls of trumps resignation on these old
allegations smack dab in the middle of
one of the greatest economic booms we've
seen perhaps since Reagan now I doubt it
especially now that we're learning that
women were being offered cash to tell
their tales of alleged misconduct by
Trump crock this entire thing is you
know in this small I'd say I caught like
this small craft advisory goes out to
everybody in the media watch the current
course you've charted lest your own
boats get swamped by the waves you
create you're reporting on the so-called
Russian collusion has been as biased and
misguided as the Muller investigation
itself you need to offer more than 24/7
demonization of our president through
leaks from Obama and Clinton partisans
or from old accusers whose stories were
already heard before election day are
you ever gonna do real reporting on how
the president is reshaping our entire
trade posture to boost US manufacturing
or maybe look into how small business
optimism is skyrocketing due to the
president's slashing of ownerís growth
killing regulations and by the way I've
had a question why does it take a group
like Judicial Watch to beat so many of
you in the media to stories about the
Muller investigation you know where are
your foyer requests or maybe you only
dig deep when it can hurt the president
I don't know and since it looks like
they've got nothing on the president and
the war on men is already backfiring
expect them to deploy even more
desperate tactics in the new year and
that's the angle